Speaker 1: Remember, we're taking calls via
discord.
If you want to be on, you have to have a nickname
that includes your name and location.
So I see a lot of one word nicknames and stuff
like that.
Just it's totally fine.
You just won't be called on.
Let's go next to Daniel in Tampa.
Daniel in Tampa.
I would love to welcome you on to the program.
And here is Daniel joining us from Tampa,
Florida.
Speaker 3: I can hear me.
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Wow.
I should be listening for two years to just
listen to everyone else talk a little while.
Welcome.
Yeah, I actually have a couple of questions.
I know that you're from Argentina, but when
did you move to the States?
Because I don't hear an accent like at all
when you speak.
Speaker 1: Well, I was five years old and
I jumped right into English.
So, yeah, I mean, other than not knowing whether
the word is anomaly or anomaly on most words,
you know, you can't tell that that I'm not.
Yeah, I'm essentially a native speaker, right?
I mean, it's sort of a joke on the program
where I say I may be misunderstanding Herschel
Walker because I speak English as a second
language.
That's not really why I can't understand Herschel
Walker, you know what I mean?
Speaker 2: Well, I don't think anyone really
understand should occur to him.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Exactly.
Speaker 3: I have one other question.
Speaker 2: You know, I believe it was a May
2021 show.
Oh, boy.
You know.
Speaker 3: On it yet.
I want to try and quote you.
You said that Argentina has a very bad history
of hiding nonwhite Argentineans.
What do I have to Google that?
A Google that in order to read like.
Speaker 1: Oh, I don't think I did.
You're saying I said of hiding nonwhite Argentineans.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Like you said, they have a bad history of
of something like hiding.
Speaker 1: It's not hiding.
Well.
So there's two different things.
Okay, let me let me break it down.
So there's you might be mixing two different
things.
Argentina has a history of hidden Nazis in
the country.
That's one thing.
And Argentina has a horrible history in.
Like, there's a reason why there's almost
no black people in Argentina.
And it's a very, very ugly history of racism
towards black people like years and years
and years ago.
Speaker 3: I think that was the second one.
What would I have to Google in order to report
it?
Because that's the first time I ever heard
that.
Speaker 1: History of African immigrants in
Argentina would probably turn up a bunch of
stuff.
I would go to Scholar Dot Google.com.
I'm sure there are papers there.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Yeah, I'll go.
But yeah, that's the only really two questions
I have for you.
All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks to things.
Things are good in Tampa.
Speaker 3: Yeah, just a little, because I
long to recall trying to drop down like 30
in the weekend.
So I'm going to I heard swing is.
Speaker 2: Going to go back up to 80.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
I hope the weather's good when I get down
there at the end of January.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah.
Speaker 2: I mean, we're lot warmer then.
So beautiful.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend.
Thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: Yeah, me too.
Speaker 1: All right.
There we go.
I don't know, guys.
I think the new system is working pretty well
here.
Using.
Using the new system and discord.
Why don't we?
The one thing, by the way, if moderators are
listening, it's hard to see people's full
nicknames because they just go to ellipses.
And so it would be interesting if there was
some way to to deal with that.
Um, but we can, we can sort of workshop that
as we go.
Let's go next to Casey from Georgia, if you
please.
Casey from Georgia, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: A long time listener.
First time caller.
Oh, great.
You, Dave.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Casey.
Welcome.
Speaker 2: Yes.
I got a quick question.
I've been seeing these ads on YouTube shine
a light on anti-Semitism.
And it's about I don't know if you're aware
of it, but I agree with most of what they
say about like the model minority stereotype
and like people complimenting people how that's
actually anti-Semitic.
But the one thing I disagree with was that
they said that if you call Israel an apartheid
state, that's inherently anti-Semitic.
And I was wondering what your opinion.
Speaker 1: I don't think calling Israel an
apartheid state is inherently anti-Semitic.
No.
I mean, the the word that's doing a lot of
heavy lifting there is inherently I don't
think it's inherently anti-Semitic.
Speaker 2: All right.
Well, thank you.
That was my question.
Speaker 1: All right.
Casey from Georgia, very good.
Appreciate that.
Let's see where we going next.
Let's go to Sal from Muscle, I guess.
Is it is it in Malden, Mass or Marlboro?
Oh, from Malden.
Sal from Malden.
Welcome.
You there.
So.
Sal, you're on live right now, but no one
can hear you.
I'm guessing you have the wrong audio device
selected.
And
is gone, powerfully gone.
That was wild.